Hello, I'm Tony Butney with VOA60 America for August 21st.
Defense Secretary Ashton Carter urged Turkey...
...to do more in fighting Islamic State and controlling its border.
Turkey agreed last month to allow US jets to attack Islamic State using an air base,...
...but has focused its increased military participation in the region...
...on its own long-running fight against Kurdish guerrillas.
The US is hoping equal attention is given to Islamic State fighters...
...crossing into Iraq and Syria from Turkey.
A deadly forest fire in Washington State has grown to nearly 40,000 hectares.
Three firefighters were killed Wednesday during their efforts.
Finally, the first two women to graduate from the grueling Army Ranger program...
...answered questions about their accomplishment.
West Point graduates Kristen Griest and Shaye Haver...
...say they hope their historic achievement will open doors for other women.